bien en el vídeo pasado nos quedamos
resolviendo el problema número 10 y
recuerda que te dije que el problema
número 10 tenía que ver con cilindros
ahora me adelantó un poco y te dibuje
aquí este cilindro que es la figura que
me ponen en el problema número 10 y por
cierto lo que me dicen es cuál es el
volumen de este cilindro bueno realmente
no me dicen esto pero vamos a sacar
primero el volumen de este cilindro que
es esencialmente el volumen de un
cilindro se calcula como pi por el radio
elevado al cuadrado por la altura y qué
otra manera lo que hay que hacer es
calcular el área de la base calculamos
el área de la base es decir pi por radio
al cuadrado porque en este caso tenemos
una circunferencia en la base ya esto lo
multiplicamos por la altura por la
altura del cilindro y bueno si nosotros
de aquí queremos obtener el volumen de
este cilindro entonces el volumen va a
ser igual a pi por el radio en este caso
el radio me dicen que vale 5 tenemos un
radio de 5 entonces por 5
elevado al cuadrado por la altura pero
la altura vale 4 x 4 muy bien entonces
el volumen de este cilindro que tengo
aquí el volumen de este va a ser igual a
pi por 25 por 4 lo cual es exactamente
lo mismo que 100 veces y muy bien ya
tengo el resultado del volumen de este
cilindro pero no es lo que me preguntan
lo que me preguntan es si tenemos el
volumen de este cilindro y lo comparamos
con el volumen de un cilindro que tenga
el mismo radio pero el doble de altura
es decir que tenga 8 unidades de altura
como podemos relacionar el volumen de
este cilindro con el volumen del
cilindro cuya altura es 8
creo que no era necesario dibujar todo
este cilindro de hecho creo que no era
necesaria ni siquiera calcular su
volumen porque esencialmente lo que me
preguntan es si yo tengo un cilindro
nuevo cuya altura es el doble de la
altura original
en cuanto a aumentar su volumen a ver
déjame ver si lo puedo dibujar por aquí
si yo quiero agarrar a este de aquí y
después lo quiero copiar y pegar a ver
control se control ven y ahora que tengo
este lo pegó justo aquí entonces ahora
si tengo un cilindro que tiene dos veces
la misma altura tengo el mismo cilindro
que la vez pasada pero este cilindro
tiene el doble de altura fíjate bien
ahora mi pregunta es cómo va a aumentar
el volumen si hacemos que la altura sea
el doble bueno pues date cuenta que este
nuevo cilindro tiene como altura 8 tiene
4 de este cilindro 4 de este cilindro
este cilindro tiene como altura de aquí
hasta acá
8 unidades y si te das cuenta lo único
que hice fue copiar y pegar dos veces el
mismo cilindro por lo tanto este
cilindro va a tener el doble de volumen
y bueno esto suena muy lógico porque
cuando hacemos que la altura sea el
doble entonces esencialmente esta
expresión aquí estoy multiplicando por
dos realmente estaba muy fácil este
problema si el volumen del cilindro de
amarillo es esta vez entonces el
cilindro que tiene altura 8 va a tener
de volumen dos veces ve y por cierto es
el inciso b ya está tenemos aquí este
problema y vamos a hacer el siguiente
problema el problema número 11 el
problema número 11 que me dice lo
siguiente guau acá
ka rombo alguna vez si los problemas
parecidos a estos son problemas de mapeo
cada rombo n
r dice k rombo n coma r es verdadero
esta expresión aquí está definida de
manera correcta está definida de manera
correcta
si se cumplen si se cumple que n es
menor que camps que a su vez te debe de
ser menor que r
y ahora me dicen si yo tengo en la
expresión menos dos rombos menos dos
rombos
en el 010 cuál de los siguientes valores
para n hace que esta correspondencia
esta relación esté definida de manera
correcta y bueno recuerda que si lo que
queremos es que esto de aquí esté
definido de manera correcta vamos a
apuntar lo que queremos que esto esté
definido de manera correcta correcta
entonces esencialmente hay que ver quién
sería cam quien sería n y quién sería r
esto está definido de manera correcta si
se cumple que n am en el stade aquí está
se mantiene igual que n tiene que ser
menor que cam casería este de aquí este
de 15 de acá menor que acá pero acá vale
menos 2 y esto tiene que ser menor que r
pero r es esta variable que tengo aquí
esto de aquí es cr entonces menor que
cero y bueno de una manera muy lógica
menos 2 es menor que cero pero lo que
estoy pidiendo es que tenga que ser
menor que menos 2
y vamos a ver los tres posibles casos
que me dan a me dan el caso uno me dan
el caso 23 y me dicen en el primer caso
tengo menos 3 en el segundo caso tengo
un -1 quieren tercer caso tengo 3
bueno buscamos un número que sea menor
que menos 23 en definitiva no es menor
que menos 2 - 1 - 1 es más grande que
menos 2 entonces esto tampoco es y menos
tres menos 3 si es menor que menos 2 por
lo tanto la respuesta correcta es el
inciso a el inciso a que me dice que
solamente el uno cumple perfecto estos
problemas donde tenemos que mapear una
relación me gusta mucho me gusta cuando
tenemos figuras extrañas en este tipo de
ejercicios pero bueno vamos en el
siguiente
así que cambiemos de color al color
magenta tengo ganas de trabajar con él
con el magenta y dice mi problema número
12 el 20% de x es exactamente lo mismo
que el 80% de james el 20% de x de x es
exactamente lo mismo que el 80% de
muy bien es lo que me pide es expresar
que en términos de x bueno cuando yo veo
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí
y déjame poner que estamos haciendo el
problema número 12 cuando yo veo esta
expresión que tengo aquí de una manera
muy sencilla no puedo pasar a su forma
de estimar es decir aquí estoy diciendo
que el 20% de x esto en su forma decimal
es el punto 20 de x el punto 20 x es
exactamente lo mismo que el 80% de james
pero en su forma decimales punto 80 de
ye porque muy bien y si yo lo que quiero
es que en términos de x pues lo único
que hay que hacer es despejar a gem y
para despejar ayer pues hay que pasar
este punto 80 del otro lado y para esto
lo voy a pasar dividiendo es decir que
james es igual a punto 20 x punto 20 x
en 3.80 en 3.80 punto 20 entre punto 80
por x es lo mismo
bueno si yo quisiera sacar esta división
de aquí pues quiero que te des cuenta
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener 2 entre 8 x estoy quitando este 0
este 0 y recorriendo el punto una vez y
después después esto es lo mismo que un
cuarto de x estoy sacando mitad arriba y
mitad abajo y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 0.25 x un cuarto lo mismo que
0.25 o dicho de otra manera
es el 25 por ciento de x si lo que
queremos hacer es regresarlo a un
lenguaje de porcentajes que por cierto
este es mi inciso b así que ya está
tengo aquí el problema número 12 y vamos
a el siguiente el problema número 13 y
qué frío hace el día de hoy a mi pie
está el lado yo creo que después de
hacer este vídeo me voy a salir a correr
o andar en bici tal vez de una vuelta en
bici a alguna colina am en fin vamos a
ver el problema 13 me dice si x x más
100 x más es para estar bueno esto por
una parte por otra parte me dice que x
más y elevado al cuadrado
x + z si me tomo la suma de todo esto me
da un número es impar me da un número
impar y me dice a partir de esto cuál de
las siguientes afirmaciones en los
incisos es siempre verdadera y el inciso
y me dice que x es impar es forzoso que
quise impar
pues vamos a ver si x + es para entonces
x más elevado al cuadrado esto de aquí
también va a ser padre estás de acuerdo
esto de aquí también es pan a un número
par elevado al cuadrado y te va a dar un
número par pero si este número es para
entonces este es número es par pero todo
este de aquí x más llegue al cuadrado
más x maceta todo esto de aquí es impar
pero si esta parte es par no me queda de
otra
esta parte de aquí x maceta debe de ser
impar x maceta debe de ser impar para
que esto me dé un número impar este de
aquí debe ser impar
de tal manera que un número par más un
número del par
este número par más este número impar me
dé un número impar es decir que tenemos
que x más bien debe ser par par pero por
otra parte x maceta no hay de otra tiene
que ser impar y tiene que ser impar y
esto sí quiero que lo entiendas muy bien
porque este número de aquí es par y si
este número de aquí es par x elevado al
cuadrado entonces para que me dé al
final un número impar tengo que sumarle
un número impar recuerda que si yo tengo
un número par ya este número par le sumó
un número impar y un par e impar
me da esto un número impar
entonces a este número par esto sumando
un número en par para que me dé un
número impar muy bien x myers para x
maceta es impar esto quiere decir que x
siempre sea impar y no forzosamente
porque puede ser que sea impar eso es
muy cierto podríamos tener que x valga 1
le valga 3 y la suma de estos medio
número par y en este caso que x valga 1
x vale 1 set amargados la suma de estos
me de un número impar esto puede ser
posible pero también no hay que
descartar que el otro caso también es
posible fíjate bien si yo tuviera que x
vale 2 que fueron número par y ya
tuviera un valor de 4 2 + 4 es un número
par y si x vale 2
iceta vale 3 2 + 3 es un número impar
por lo tanto x no forzosamente es impar
puede ser par o impar y de hecho el
inciso b me dice que si x forzosamente
spark y bueno de igual manera no
forzosamente esto es cierto
aquí en el sitio se historia se pone más
interesante porque me dice si se está si
se está es para sí se está es para
entonces forzosamente x tiene que ser
impar x tiene que ser impar y esto es
cierto bueno pues si zeta
es un número par es más volvemos todo
esto si se está es 4 es un número par
entonces x tiene que ser un número impar
forzosamente para que el resultado de
que es maceta me dé un número impar
recuerda que a un número par cuando le
sumamos un número impar me da un número
en paz
justo lo que tengo aquí arriba y por lo
tanto el insisto se siempre es cierto si
se está es parte no queda de otra
x forzosamente tiene que ser impar tal
manera que esto porque hay equis macetas
debe de ser impar y entonces mi
respuesta correcta es el 12 y como
solamente tenemos una respuesta correcta
ya está mi respuesta sería el inciso c
qué bueno este estuvo un poco confuso
pero solamente hay que pensar en números
pares e impares así que borramos la
pantalla y voy a ver si me queda tiempo
para hacer el último problema de este
vídeo el problema número 14 vamos a ver
si me da tiempo para resolverlo
sí creo que no está tan difícil podemos
resolverlo dice 0 es menor que x que a
su vez es menor que 1 es decir x está
entre 0 y 1 entonces cuál es las
siguientes afirmaciones es verdadera y
la primera me dice lo siguiente x
cuadrada es mayor que x al cubo
bien la segunda me dicen x es mayor que
x sobre 2 muy bien la tercera me dice
que x es más grande que x elevado al
cubo
ok para resolver este problema y ya que
sabemos que este examen es un examen de
tiempo entonces para no quebrar nos la
cabeza voy a pensar en un valor entre 0
y 1 y creo que el mejor valor sería un
medio el que está justo a la mitad un
medio vamos a ver si un medio al
cuadrado es más grande que un medio el
cubo es decir un cuarto
más grande que un octavo y bueno pues
esto es cierto tener un cuarto de pastel
siempre es mejor que tener un octavo de
pastel entonces este se cumple
el número dos dice un medio es más
grande que un medio entre dos un medio
entre dos pues esto es lo mismo que un
cuarto y un medio es más grande que un
cuarto pues en definitiva así yo
prefiero tener la mitad del pastel a
tener solamente un cuarto del pastel por
lo tanto también se cumple esta y la
tercera dice un medio un medio es más
grande que un octavo que un medio al
cubo y bueno pues la respuesta de esto
pues claramente es que si entonces las
tres se cumplen y el inciso que me dice
que las tres se cumplen es el insisto y
muy bien estuvo bien fácil este pero
bueno me he quedado sin tiempo así que
ha sido todo por este vídeo pero nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo donde voy a
resolver el problema número 15 hasta